c'est un bon moment
il est patient il est passionné
un peu partout donc du coup si quelqu'un
qui est bougé aussi c'est dans sa nature
en fait moi à l'atelier je peux rien
faire du tout pour l'aider puis il se
débrouille il se dépadent je sais pas
trop comment il fait mais il est partout
à la Réunion il y a ça aussi donc faut
aller trouver quelque chose qui pourrait
se venir aux besoins de la famille quand
on a une grande famille comme la nôtre
il faut
cinq enfants et le sixième bientôt
avant et après
tous mes outils fabriqués dans la
récupération
faut pas le métier qui va n'importe où
n'importe comment parce que c'est un
métier ne va déjà plus ou moins
dangereux
donc ça ça sort du commerce
donc celui-là va durer on va dire deux
trois années cela peut durer jusqu'à 20
ans
oui ben l'artiste se crée au fur et à
mesure en travaillant et en forgeant
parce que au début
remplacer je vois pas le disparaître
malgré je suis le dernier à La Réunion